sauvez vous douce nouvelle urgente
batman au micro avis à tous nos amis
message extrêmement important c'est
capital
c'est palpitant assez de superlatifs
batman et venons en au fait bientôt très
bientôt
batman et moi nous vivrons pour votre
plaisir et votre distraction une de nos
plus extraordinaire aventure fait exact
robin vous verrez un film qui vous
passionnera plein de péripéties
haletante de rebondissements d'action et
d'éclat
nous roulerons à toute vitesse dans
notre batmobile le survoleront l'océan
aux commandes de notre bad cop terre
pour faire mordre la poussière au plus
terrible poids thouars du crime que le
monde ait jamais fut le minimum qu'ils
aient pu projeter c'est d'attaquer la
terre entière
voici les quatre infâme gredins contre
lesquelles nous luttons la femme chat
vous assisterez au plus parfait des
crimes quand je tiendrai batman dans me
griffe
le jockey cette farce râle interne hier
elle sera fatale badman le pingouin le
paraguay n'est pas manchot ils vont
l'apprendre à leurs dépens
batman et robin le sphinx question qui
saura mettre au pas un attrape nigaud
qui enverra pac man et andine sur le
carreau dans notre bat cave nous sommes
très bien équipée pour combattre ces
génies du mal et nous avons aussi le bad
cop terre ici je lutte avec un requin
piégé par une sardine
là je suis prisonnier d'un aimant et
voici le sous marin des criminels a mis
à taper première partie
mais nous avons notre bas de cadeaux
leur arme suprême le déshydratateurs
ils attaquent notre bat cave c'est une
hallucination et 4 super timide elle se
déplace en pagne parapluie
mais moi robin je scrute mon bas d'écran
et je file le parfait amour de batman
mais devant une fusée polaris les plus
forts s'incline cramponne toi robin
cette fois c'est peut être bien la fin
et ce n'est là qu'un bref échantillon
des exploits et des extraordinaires
aventures de batman et robin
alors n'oubliez pas de voir la suite
fait un e à votre mouchoir
ce sera le mot de la fin
me